she the invitation to
to be here and to talk to you about BGP
it's the thing that I've been studying
for probably the last 15 years it is
indeed the good the bad and the ugly of
Internet routing it's a very simple
protocol and it's being used as you said
by by people who probably never
anticipated to be participants in it at
scales that we never would have imagined
so you do a very simple thing at
unreasonably large scale and what
happens can be really mysterious so
rather than focus on maybe some of the
technical minutiae of the rfcs which you
can go read today I'm going to take you
on a walk through some of the really
interesting emergent phenomena that
happen when you get tens of thousands of
organizations to speak this little
protocol that that originally was just
spoken by a few people so today what I'd
like you to take you through is perhaps
a statement of the core problem if
you're going to look at this as a
research problem which is one of
attribution and belief what is the
ground truth of IP addressing on the
internet is it ever true that an IP
address equals a building or a machine
or person we talk about attacks coming
from IP addresses and yet if you look
down at the fundamentals of how routing
actually works you realize that there is
not as much certainty there as we hope
so we're going to walk through some
examples of how bgp kind of works in
cartoon form with some real participants
and some real some real language about
how people actually connect and then
we'll take a tour of some of the
terrible terrible things that people do
to each other through using the bgp so
we're going to play a couple games maybe
some spots some evil and we'll look at
some of the worst things that are being
done in the last few years down in the
plumbing where nobody's paying attention
if I just go to perhaps my background a
little bit it might help to explain how
how I got to to this point I started my
career in the 1990s doing
high-performance computing and at that
point DARPA was looking at the problems
of building larger and larger scale
machines in the early 90s that kind of
networking meant very very high speed
networks that you put in a cabinet we're
in a building
right they were building supercomputers
that we're building scale at best and it
was around that time as we get towards
the middle of the 90s that if you've
ever been working on a research agenda
and you start getting a little voice in
the back of your head that something
else more interesting is happening it
started to happen to us and I think it
started to happen to DARPA as well they
realized that the internet was was had
been a use of course for 20 years but
now the web had appeared it was causing
a lot of new use cases and a lot of
people to join because it was the killer
app that were causing dynamics that
nobody really understood and so in a
very adroit move for a large research
organization DARPA decided to start
funding research into how internet
dynamics behaved and we were there
looking at initially we wanted to look
at how people might participate using
the World Wide Web to do high
performance computing right you take
small steps from where you are initially
I had the good fortune to work with some
of the folks who were doing large
integer factorization projects we had
the number field sieve errs out there
working away on projects that could be
broken up into pieces and distributed
and the results posted back so we built
one of the the very early systems for
passing at work and recombining work and
have an early forerunner of Seti at home
and this was in nineteen ninety I want
to say seven or eight and that was
interesting right we suddenly realized
that there were a lot more cpus there's
a lot more memory accessible to us if we
could get out there and bring everybody
in on these projects then we could build
even with the most lucrative lee funded
single building project the next step
really from a funding perspective was to
go look at simulation and modeling so we
said we're going to have we were getting
we were quoting things like tens of
thousands of nodes participating on the
internet what would happen and we wanted
to review what would happen if you
change parameters in TCP what would
happen if you modified BGP what sort of
chaos could you model and we started to
build using our high-performance
computing and parallelization expertise
some of the tools for understanding what
internet looked like at those
else pretty soon as we rounded the
millennium we were looking at doing
larger and larger simulations of the
internet we developed these enormous
data sets for what had happened we
realized we had no visualization we had
no analytics we were going to have to
build the tool chain in order to figure
out what had happened in the experiment
was no longer the constrained to run the
experiment before that was what we
worried about how many seconds will it
take to run this on the processors i
have now it became how many weeks is it
going to take me to understand what i
did and so we started a company called
Renesys that initially was just going to
do that we were going to study the
internet in modeling and simulation
space and very quickly it became clear
that we could start to pull in some of
the real world data sets what was
actually happening on the real routing
table there were sites available that
would give you raw dumps of the BGP
update traffic you know they would give
you snapshots of the routing table and
you could go in and mine these and
figure out what was going on during real
events I was stranded in in Leiden in
the Netherlands during 911 and I
remember looking that day at some of the
effects of routing through New York as
buildings came down and realizing this
was very concrete right this was how the
world was really evolving and instead of
just being in modeling and simulation we
could actually see it going on so we did
this for a long time in last year we
actually merged forces with dine as an
internet performance company that does
some of them managed DNS the
authoritative and secondary DNS for some
of the most important properties on the
internet and it's in that that
combination that we're going to try to
start to see some very concrete ways to
reach out to people help them do
business on the internet in a way that
you know it's high performance and take
away a lot of the mystery about how
people actually get from A to B and this
is the playground that I get to play on
every day this is what we built we've
got virtual servers and physical servers
all around the globe we're doing live
traceroute measurements to about a
million and a half curated targets every
day so we're collecting several billion
measurements of round-trip latency and
paths
we're putting that up against the bgp
mountain the the real-time map of how
everything connects to everything using
the border gateway protocol which will
show today and so on that playground
every day there are more things to look
at then there are eyeballs and hours to
survey the things that happen so let's
take a look here I said that this was
going to be the motivational problem the
problem is one of attribution and belief
I'll give you an IP address I say I'm
being attacked from this IP address what
kind of credibility was sort of credence
should you give that association between
an IP and some kind of real world domain
like a geography or a person or
organization so the answer is not much
because the underlying routing protocols
are very very easy to confuse the whole
thing is based on trust that trust can
be subverted it can be subverted in ways
that hide the truth from almost
everybody on earth and confuse a very
specific subset of people and so they're
really it's very very hard to Authority
lycée this IP address was doing this to
me at this time there are actually
legitimate scenarios right where a
single IP address is supposed to be
hundreds or thousands of machines and it
doesn't even have to be a single point
on earth so yeah you can think of that
as a purely intentional form of
spreading an address around the world
we're going to take a look here at some
of the cases where that happens
unintentionally or maliciously so I
don't know if you have a lot of
familiarity with BGP itself I will kind
of gloss over but for the core
vocabulary is important for what follows
this is the protocol that runs the
internet BGP is used inside autonomous
systems organizations on the internet
but of course it's also used exclusively
pretty much between autonomous systems
it's what makes networks into the
internet work it is based on a couple of
rfcs which you can read at your leisure
today there are about 49,000 perhaps a
little more autonomous systems doing
this each one does BGP according to its
own rules so it can keep itself
connected to everybody else in that
graph
okay so people have their own networks
their own assigned blocks of IP
addresses they advertise these to there
to there bgp neighbors and magic happens
everybody independently picks the best
path to everything else that they might
want to reach and as that converges
based on all of those local decisions at
49,000 different autonomous systems the
whole thing meshes up and traffic goes
on its way ok so the protocol itself is
really really simple I've seen smart
undergrads write this you know you know
in a in a week-long project you can
write a BGP speaker that will be
conformant and and and to attend for all
intents and purposes it is a BGP speaker
like a cisco router the protocol is
simple but the policy is complex because
everybody gets to make their own rules
this is the rule of the internet right
my network my rules I can decide what I
want to accept what I want to reject
what I want to propagate not propagate
and it's purely based on my decision and
so that's great because this is what
allows Internet routing to change with
the times and to adopt different
economic models different business
models because we're not all locked into
one firm policy worldwide the other hand
this flexibility is what allows us to
shoot each other in the foot which we do
every day so let's work an example ok
this is we're going to start here with
the autonomous system numbers these used
to be 16 bits for over five years these
have been 32 bit ince although there's
still lots and lots of routing equipment
in the world that gets hopelessly
confused and does not understand that
you can have an AS number greater than
16 bits it's mysterious I mean when you
think about what it takes to upgrade the
internet you can troll a truck and
upgrade the internet you have to
persuade everybody on earth to upgrade
the internet and they do it slowly over
time something as simple as moving from
16 to 32 bit AAS numbers takes years and
that's just a very simple change that is
done for them by the equipment vendors
um these AAS numbers are given out of
course by the regional registries and
they were given out in order so if you
ever see an AS number in this
presentation that has a small number
no this is one of the early days I won't
say a dinosaur but this is one of the
the primordial autonomous systems so
Stanford got it nice and early not quite
as early as Yale but Stanford has 32
okay as you move forward in a s number
space you start to see different people
starting to make money so level 3 comes
in at 3356 level 3 actually bought BBN
so they actually have a s number one and
they don't use it which is mysterious to
me china telecom came in in the for
thousands microsoft arrives around 8,000
google doesn't show up until 15,000 they
didn't even get a four digit AAS number
it's kind of shameful and then as you go
out in history use find commercial
organizations kind of the last guys to
the party buying these 32-bit a/s
numbers in the last couple years so Bank
of Taiwan is up there in the 130
thousands and Nomura so here's a
scenario okay we're going to put some of
these a s numbers to work this is a
complete scenario for a potential BGP
hijacking but I made this up so if you
know somebody your cousin works at one
of these companies do not have them send
lawyers to me because this is fictitious
I had to pick something to go through
that would make sense but it's not real
we will look at some real examples next
from history so let's imagine let's pick
on the Nomura group so no more a group
is in Tokyo and they have 1970 39 and
they have this autonomous system number
which was assigned to them it by ripe in
the UK why because they operate they
took over somebody's failing trading
floor infrastructure in the big crash of
2008 remember who it was and so they
they have this autonomous system so they
could operate in London okay they've
been given eight no sorry 11 ipv4
address blocks blocks of space that
belong to them belong in quotation marks
because theoretically you don't really
own IP space you borrow it from humanity
for a given time but they have these 11
blocks and each one of these blocks
contains a certain number of unique IP
addresses that only they should be using
they used a number their infrastructure
right in London so let's pick one of
these there's 194 362
41 / 24 so / 24 is important because it
shows you how many significant bits
there are in the IP address in the in
the prefix so I would call it a prefix
24 bits leaves you 8 bits at the end for
numbering your machines so you get 256
addresses for your trading floor okay so
far so good now no more wants to speak
BGP they want to make sure everybody on
earth can reach this / 24 and all those
machines so they'll go out and spend
some money nomura knows how to spend
money they'll go out and buy transit IP
transit from two different providers and
these are numerous actual real providers
in London one is Colt a very good
network in Europe the other one is
verizon notice that this is they have a
nice low AS number because 702 secretly
used to be uunet europe right so this is
an old inherited network they're paying
money that's what Transit is right
you're paying money to somebody for the
promise of global delivery peering is
something different I mean every time
you establish an adjacency in BGP it's
peering but peering is different from
transit traditionally peering takes
place between customer bases people are
showing each other their customers and
they'll say i'll give you routes to mine
if you give me routes to yours and we
won't pay any money and then everybody
saves money on transit so ideally you'd
never have to pay for transit in point
of fact there's only maybe a dozen
organizations on earth who can say that
everybody else still has to buy a little
transit so here's nomura they've bought
transit from two guys paid some money
cult of course is a european network
they can't actually take your traffic
everywhere on Earth even though that's
what buying transit means so they kind
of lied well to make that lie truth they
have to go out and lay it off it's kind
of like insurance and reinsurance so
they go ahead and they buy from Deutsche
Telekom they buy from level three so if
Nomura sends a packet to the United
States a packet goes up to cult cult
says right okay you take it level three
level three is getting money from cult
who's getting money from Nomura the
money goes out the traffic comes back
and they keep everybody connected now
Deutsche Telekom and level 3 don't make
as much money in this stage because this
wholesale aggregation and we're talking
at this point about you know cents per
megabit it's so very thin as you get up
into wholesale now we keep doing this
okay
I can't fit 49,000 a s is on the slide
so here's you know six or seven it just
keeps going so everybody on earth
transitively has relationships now that
reach back through the chain the a s
path to nomura so in case anybody on
earth Russia you know anybody Siemens
wants to send traffic to the trading
floor of new era in London they have a
way to get there it's connected up most
people are paying money some people
there in the core exchanging they're not
paying any money but it all works out
that's incredible you know this is what
we kind of had a hard time believing
imagining could ever happen and there at
the mid end of the 90s that this could
scale up just based on that one
relationship style to almost 50,000 a
esas today they all speak BGP to each
other the same way they've decided you
know we've looked at one prefix here but
there's over half a million of these
things out there everybody's got a route
is there's maybe 20,000 ipv6 networks we
probably won't get to v6 today focus on
sort of the broad base of the internet
v4 but you know it's interesting because
autonomous systems are buying transit
from each other most have forty percent
of them only have one kind of degenerate
forty percent have to that's better
twenty percent have three or more that's
good diversity that's what you want to
see and so the amazing thing is that in
this enormous graph this worldwide graph
anybody on earth can change anything you
know oh I got a new route I've got a new
network and within 30 seconds every
other router on earth that speaks BGP
that has a full table will hear about it
and adjust accordingly and the pads will
all have converged it's pretty
extraordinary you imagine that a single
randomly selected path through this
graph is about 5.3 hops so there's me
and the guy I'm trying to talk to and
three guys in the middle who don't even
have a contractual relationship with me
or him necessarily and yet it works out
in any way it's like a whisper game or
play the whisper game so I send out my
announcements of course I have to send
money with my announcements to make sure
that people will pay attention
as I send out my announcements and my
money traffic starts to arrive at my
site and everybody does this it's
symmetric all around the internet okay
so far so good well okay first moment of
concern on slide 21 what happens if no
more a guy gets up in the morning and he
types the wrong number into a router
config and he publishes it so if i send
out a bogus route announcement what will
happen nothing should happen right
you're advertising space you don't
legitimately sort of lay claim to
hopefully nothing will happen hopefully
no traffic will actually come back in
fact it doesn't really work that way so
this guy has changed the third octet
from 241 to 252 and suddenly he's
squatting on space that's owned by
wedgwood UK those people who make the
beautiful china that people get in their
wedding registries and he doesn't own
this space he has no business routing
this but he's pushed it up there to
colton verizon hopefully colton verizon
say we'll wait a minute you've never
advertised that before that's not even
your space you know i'm going to filter
that i'm not going to allow you to
spread that to the rest of the internet
now practically speaking many many many
service providers still do not comply
with the best best common practice of
filtering customer routes to put these
illegitimate things on the side instead
they'll happily turn around and
advertise them to everybody else on
earth and in just a few seconds everyone
on earth will believe that Wedgwood
China this unused block of space is
legitimately hosted on the trading floor
of numeira in London so why wouldn't
they filter well it's work right
internet transit business is pretty
pretty skinny margins these days there's
not a lot of time people or money which
are all equivalent to go hunting these
things down and doing a really good job
as much as we the community would prefer
it to be so so some people set max pref
that's a an attribute you can set on a
session so if somebody suddenly
advertises a thousand prefixes they will
blow through max pref
this maximum number that session will
get torn down somebody will figure it
out and there'll be some delay and some
outage that helps with big leaks but it
doesn't help with this one leak
sometimes people build static lists of
things that their customers are allowed
to do that's a good idea sometimes they
go to the routing registries where
people are kind of honor bound to put at
least some record of what they're trying
to route so people can compare it
against reality and say well wait a
minute this is quite match up so in fact
is people do a really poor job of that
maintaining those registries people try
they build automated filters from it and
this stuff still gets through okay Oh
continuously and yeah every day yes
somewhere yes what happens if instead of
parking on an unused space somebody far
side used space excellent question this
is what happens right here okay so these
guys okay Wedgwood UK was fine they
probably didn't even notice they weren't
using that space seriously they probably
never would notice such a thing but what
if they changed one digit in that route
that they published may change it to a
zero so now it's an early octet which
means that they're outside the local
region where these numbers were being
given out and it's longer distance
failure these guys have just squatted on
a piece of can TV which is an important
access network in Venezuela in and the
problem here is that there are probably
people using this space in Caracas it's
actively used so what's going to happen
well now we have a fight okay we've got
two routes in the routing table
Venezuela is putting out a / 16 great
big network to cover all of their
Caracas subscribers and nomura just came
along in this fictitious example and
injected a little covering route or a
little more specific route the / 24 now
a problem here is BGP likes more
specifics the protocol was designed so
that you give it looks for the most
specific route the most the smallest
most direct network to those addresses
that can find and if it sees a big 16
and a small 24 it will zero in on the
small 24 that's one of the mechanisms
that was used for providers to give out
pieces of their space as it was intended
okay send traffic towards the a s who
actually made the most specific
announcement well great that little hole
that we've just punched in the / 16
that's now going to go to London and
it's going to happen silently and the
folks in Venezuela unless they're using
some very sophisticated route table
monitoring tools may not actually notice
that anything is wrong they may see that
route pop-up they may not have any way
in the NOC of knowing that it's there
because they didn't expect it to be
there what they'll actually see is a
drop in traffic so all the traffic from
that's closer to the hijacker this is a
hijack all of traffic that was
originated closer to the hijacker in BGP
space is going to go to the hijacker and
all that traffic is going to fail to
show up in Caracas and that's what
they're going to notice right so yeah
I'm outer space or physical geometry I'm
actually talking about the number space
so we have this graph of the autonomous
systems and an AS path is a the shortest
identified path through that graph to
the origin from the questioner so it's
in that space and that space does not
necessarily have anything to do with
physical geography which is why this can
get really strange so okay this seems
you can't believe that this actually
works for a planetary Internet how do we
get this far with this protocol you can
do anything you want you can say
anything you want and if nobody filters
you if nobody calls BS it'll happen
right there is no central or even
hierarchical authority that you could
consult to say is this really a good
idea and actually that's why we built it
that way the founders of the internet we
had this had this this fear of
centralized Authority which i think is
pretty healthy because they knew if
there were a centralized registry where
you could go for the authoritative word
on whether you could do that it would
get captured by somebody who had some
power and because it doesn't exist it
can't be captured but it spreads the
responsibility to everybody else okay
well that's just theoretically let's see
some real anomalies ok that was just a
fictitious example let's take a look at
how this is actually played out
throughout time and let's put it in the
form of a game I like games because
they're interactive this is simple
protocol it's being played in a complex
world emergent phenomena take place it
can be very very hard for experts to
tell whether these are legitimate
routings or evil routings so you guess
do five of these five is about as many
as I can stomach so here's number one we
get reports from a building in Singapore
that people on two different floors of
the building what's safe floor 10 and
floor 11 have different service
providers we're trying to talk to each
other on the internet and its really
slow it takes 350 milliseconds for a
packet to get from floor 10 to 4 11 I
think that's pretty strange so they go
to their network folks and they say can
you run a trace route and they trace it
and they find out it's going through a
mysterious data center in California
evil do you think some people that's the
way economics works what you have here
is two providers one of which has more
power in the Singapore market than the
other one and refuses to peer he says
I'm not gonna exchange traffic with you
locally unless you pay me and the other
guy says i'm not i'm a huge
international provider i'm not paying
you fine well you're not going to meet
me in singapore so they go meet each
other at the only other closest place
they can meet each other which is in san
jose at one of these big buildings and
the traffic goes there and comes back
and everybody's happy because they
didn't get they didn't pay any money to
somebody they didn't want to pay and
they didn't cave in and peer with
somebody they were religiously don't
appear with and everything's fine except
that the traffic takes 350 milliseconds
it goes across the ocean twice
completely normal here's scenario 2 i'm
sending traffic from germany to new york
city and i measured the traffic and
takes about 70 milliseconds and i do a
traceroute and it goes through iceland
along the way goes like frankfurt london
Iceland Montreal New York
that evil is that expected expectant oh
it's very unusual that sounds right
doesn't it sounds plausible it almost
looks like a great circle route but
there are lots of submarine cables that
can get you from London to New York and
one-hop right no no reason to come
ashore in Iceland you don't have to
regenerate the IP packets or something
and nobody would ever come ashore in
Iceland to carry traffic between Europe
in the United States because it would
add actually had latency because it's
not on the Great Circle Route it would
add cost because there's a provider in
the middle taking a cut what actually
happened here was and this was a real
incident there was a provider in Iceland
that was advertising United States space
space from all over actually in Europe
pulling the traffic to them putting it
back on the network in Montreal letting
it go and it should not have happened
and yet it did look at that a little
more detail in a second here's number
three okay this one's a google example
okay we're measuring so one of the ways
you can tell where something is is to
measure time it takes to get there right
speed of light is you can't really fool
the speed of light things take a certain
amount of time to go from A to B so
we're measuring along how long does it
take to get public dns to answer a
question from South America takes these
you can see the latency the time is on
the x-axis the latency on the Y this is
from South American observation points
takes a certain amount of time until it
doesn't so suddenly in October 2013 it
takes a lot longer okay normal we're not
let's just go ahead it's not evil right
as Google can't be evil so what actually
happened is this is any cast right any
cast is where you announce the same
thing in lots of places I deliberately
spread this IP address all over the
planet and you will rely on BGP to take
you to the closest instance okay so
there were some political things going
on there was some internet governance
issues raised in brazil around this time
and suddenly the brazilian instances of
public dns weren't answering anymore and
everybody had to go to California
instead that's that jump in latency and
then in february2014 that gets sorted
out and wait and C's go back to where
they were
because Brazil starts to answer again I
don't know what that is it's not
engineering it's not evil that's just
economics and politics here's that
here's a related one so imagine that I
have a domain where people are
downloading really critical stuff like
software updates and this thing takes a
certain number of milliseconds about 25
milliseconds when I measure it from
Eastern Europe going back to Western
Europe which is where the server lives
and one day performance really improves
it becomes less than five milliseconds
and then it goes back the way it was
well it was weird what do you think is
that evil yeah that's that one's really
evil because what happened you can't
fool the speed of light if you're in
Eastern Europe you've got to get to
Western Europe and you're getting it in
two milliseconds something has gone
terribly wrong so this is what actually
happened this site was the IP address
was something had that IP address and
was answering in the immediate local
neighborhood you know the phone calls
coming from inside the house this is
that and and when you see that you
immediately start thinking well how wide
was that pattern of disruption and why
would somebody do that sometimes you end
up with more questions than answers
right last one last one scenario 52 good
friends on the internet big a esas
powerful AS IS Russian VimpelCom
enormous carrier and China Telecom
China's sort of biggest state telco
internet provider good friends have
connection together their peers so
VimpelCom advertises seven thousand of
customer prefixes to China Telecom
saying here if you need to reach my
Russian customers here are the routes in
China Telecom says thank you and
announces them out the door to all of
its other peers in China Telecom says
here VimpelCom here are 300,000 networks
i can reach on my network feel free to
use them and of course traffic on that
link goes way up wow this is great we're
sharing so much stuff normal or no it's
not not even vaguely this is a terrible
idea I don't know if this was deliberate
or accidental but remember if you're
peering transit
says I give you traffic you take it
where it goes no questions asked i paid
you peering is we're only supposed to
share our customers right if you really
ring routes to your peers what you have
done is accidentally become a transit
provider for free there may be reasons
to do that I can't think of any really
good ones and this is what happened so
here's an actual trace that we ran while
this was going on tracing from Moscow to
New Hampshire and you might expect that
to go right across the ocean instead it
goes Moscow Frankfurt Frankfurt into
China Telecom hey wait what's going on
here giant telecom takes it to Shanghai
wait whoa you know Shanghai Los Angeles
and then back across the United States
comes in San Jose goes through Chicago
goes to cleveland goes to albany and
it's in new hampshire the wrong way
around the world well that's what
happens if you accidentally become a
transit provider and this lasted for a
long time giving away transit and by the
by intercepting a lot of Russian traffic
that was going to places all over the
world pretty neat any questions at this
point sort of on these sort of
fundamental things this is just a
sampling right these are the sort of
stories we publish some of these on our
blog there's a lot of small fish that we
catch in these nets that we just turn
loose because we don't have enough time
to to examine them all bgp hijacks let's
take a look at just what we've actually
seen yes this is a position to monitor
this stuff well so we are thank you it's
not a placed question there are
commercial services that you can use to
allow you to monitor your own networks
to make sure this stuff doesn't happen
to your networks you can even use it to
monitor the world if you are so inclined
and there are actually public data sets
that you can mine through by yourself
and I'll identify some of them at the
end of the talk in case people want to
get into this game of finding anomalies
because it's a rewarding game but
there's nobody tasked with that job and
I've talked to people at for example
anissa the people who do cybersecurity
in Europe and this is I think this is
going to turn out to be a real concern
it's know you've got states
effectively manipulating the routing of
other states and at that level it
becomes a something that that larger
people should watch you know not just us
shouldn't just be the citizens on the
net who keep an eye on this so what was
neat in 2013 was one more wrinkle so
everything I've discussed so far is
actually pretty straightforward okay
here's the next iteration this is a real
innovative model so again we'll go
through the pecking order so as you said
you know if you if you squat on space
it's not even being used it's just rude
you shouldn't do that but you're not
harming anybody really right you're not
taking away their traffic if you exact
match somebody you say I know you have
this but i also have it well now I've
stolen all the traffic from everybody
who is closer to me in autonomous system
space not geographic space so if I'm
well connected you know if I'm a big
provider at huge internet exchanges I
may actually be able to seize a large
amount of traffic from very far away
places that you wouldn't expect so
that's a little ruder let's get Reuters
still I take all of your traffic you
know Sears youtube in pakistan well i'll
just put one out there that you know
you're going to basically give you a
complete denial of service on what
you're addressing how about even more
I'll take your address space and because
i know that bgp loves more specifics
i'll break it up into bite-sized pieces
and I'll advertise all of it and if I
take it out to / 24 which is the tiniest
block most people will publicly route in
today's internet you can't even get it
back because you can't go to the 25 to
try to outdo me in this game you're
stuck at the most the the smallest block
you can publicly route all we can do is
fight for it on a block-by-block basis
that's really evil but it pales in
comparison to the man in the middle man
in the middle is where I lie to some
part of the world and I get your traffic
and I do something with it I put it back
on the internet I make sure you get it
just as if nothing had happened that's
worse than actually taking your traffic
and not giving it to you right
the way this actually works this is the
other things we've talked about the
typos the fat finger mistakes on router
configs these could all be explained
away we've had them explained away to us
many times oh I i inverted two digits
you know I edit distance one you know
this this you can't do this accidentally
this has to be constructed so what I do
I'm the hijacker here in the middle I I
create two different routing zones
around me I partition all of my
adjacencies into two sets let's call
them clean and dirty so on the dirty
side I lie to people I say I'm the
victim victim this way come this way and
the traffic comes my way and I have the
traffic and then I turn around to my
other unaffected peers and I say I don't
know what this is this is going to this
other guy I I put it back on the net and
my transit providers typically will just
deliver it they'll put it they'll get it
back to its intended recipient and the
intended recipient doesn't even realize
anything happened because his traffic
volumes didn't change all it happened is
it got a little slower and if I pick my
spot correctly it may not even get a lot
slower maybe even gets faster so this
technique was first described by Tony
capella did a great job of this at Def
Con 16 way back in two thousand eight
and he did this in the best possible way
for the show which was he did it to the
show network he took all of their
traffic and he redirected it through his
own stuff by announcing more specifics
attacking the traffic and then putting
it back and if you ran trace route so
you could see well all the show traffic
is now going through my server and that
was pretty scary it got a lot of
people's attention in 2008 we went back
at black hat and did a talk in 2009
where we actually went through all the
data in history since we started
recording back in 2001 and said well the
good news is this has never been seen in
the wild the only one we found was Tony
and not anybody else and so well that's
good the attack was a subtle one there's
a thing in BGP called loop detection
so if I receive a BGP update it's
already got my a s number in the path
I'm supposed to throw that away I just
throw it on the floor because i don't
want loops to start happening in routing
protocols right that's you can imagine
the sort of amplification and disaster
that would result so if I see my own ASI
say oh all right I've been here before
throw that away well an attacker can use
that you just put there a s in the path
as you rewrite the path before you send
the announcement on and then what's
happened is everybody else in the world
believes you and the victim never
actually gets to see any of the evidence
because all the routes that show that
he's been hijacked never reached him the
subtle tea ramps up from there ok as you
can imagine when people really want to
do something and when they're good at it
they will study all the different ways
to make this happen in subtler and
subtler ways so we saw people use bgp
communities these little optional
attributes you can add two announcements
to make sure that the lies that you put
out only propagate to certain people
that they never make it back to the
victim or in fact they never make it
back to a global scope where somebody
might be watching to figure it out we
saw people try to announce only to peers
for example right and not transit
providers knowing that peering typically
is more localized so I'm trying to
attract traffic from an immediate
neighborhood and then i use my transit
providers as my clean path to get it
back on its way so i want to attract
traffic from my local neighborhood
that's headed to the victim quick detour
through my data center back on the net
you never figure out anything else is
happening ok and it works really well as
i said if you're somebody who has a lot
of peering a lot of adjacencies you're a
very well connected guy you can get huge
amounts of traffic this way so here's
what we saw in 2013 and we put this on
their NSS blog bell telecom is the
Belarusian incumbent provider and there
were lots of downstream a esas customers
of Bel telecom who put routes apparently
into the table claiming to be various
other people in the world these were the
hijacked prefixes these were things all
over all over the world but there were a
lot of them in the United States
we were able because we have this hybrid
infrastructure we're both watching the
routing and we're doing traceroute
active monitoring we were able to launch
traces during these attacks and find out
what routers were passed through on the
way the traces go through Bell telecom
they don't really go through these
customers who are originating it here's
the other one we talked about was the
Icelandic one right here's a traffic
graph from that time you can see spikes
in traffic well yeah they were getting
spikes in traffic because they were
announcing other people's prefixes in
Europe and when we ran traces through
them while the attacks were going on if
they were in fact attacks they could
have been misconfigurations you can see
that traces were going through Iceland
and back into Canada and then on to the
origin and when we talked to them they
said well yeah okay you're right we did
redirect some traffic there was a router
software bug this was a sort of a
classic thing and we fixed it and they
fixed it it didn't happen again but it
resulted in some really weird things
okay so these are a little hard to see
but let me let me describe so the green
is the way traffic normally goes and red
is the way we saw traffic going so we
actually captured these traces live so
normally i want to go from New York to
Los Angeles well during the attack it
goes New York London wait a minute we're
going the wrong way london to moscow
because that's how you get to Minsk
Minsk okay now we go back on the clean
side back to Frankfurt back to New York
second time in New York and over to Los
Angeles so good I exactly how should be
there couldn't that must be a typo yeah
here's how we get from Frankfurt to
fremont california during the icelandic
event so normally you know you're going
from Europe to California you just hop
across the pond you're in New York
you're in Washington take it across the
country san jose fremont done during the
event we we see it go all over the place
I mean starts in Frankfurt goes to
London up to wreck you Vic that's the
hop that should not happen
back to Montreal down to New York over
to San Jose and we're done bizarre
here's my favorite one my favorite
traceroute out of all the hundreds of
millions of traces that we processed in
this experiment I'm this is like our
Singapore example with the office
building right I got two guys in Denver
they've got different service providers
now if you have different service
providers the way BGP works okay if
they're not on best of terms locally
things may happen so normally in the
green you can see it goes Denver Dallas
Kansas City Denver that's not terrible
right at least it's in the right region
but during this event the traffic starts
in Denver goes to Chicago goes to
ashburn virginia up to New York over to
London up to wreck you Vic back to
Montreal back to Chicago back to ashburn
again and then back to Dallas and
finally to Denver okay we've gone across
town and we've gone through Iceland just
amazing that more of these things were
not discovered by users but users in
this day and age are actually fairly
tolerant of higher Layton sees and
people may not have noticed anything was
happening so you know to the question
can this be fat fingering can it just be
accidents it's very hard we go back we
look at the archive remember dine
Renesys at this time is recording all
the BGP update traffic that we collect
from over three or four hundred
different sessions with providers all
over the world so we get to kind of do
an instant replay back through these
moments of time and routing and we can
see that there are communities being
applied to these routes specifically
saying things that make sense to those
peers saying I want you not to give this
to your international peers I do not
want you to announce this outside of our
region keep this local but announce it
to everybody locally right because
you're trying to get as many people as
possible locally in the geographic
region to send you the traffic but you
need the clean path so don't announce
this to anybody internationally or the
jig will be up it's very hard to do
accidentally so this happened in in 2013
we actually saw this on over a hundred
different days there was something like
this going on to some
which is rather extraordinary thousands
of networks being targeted there were
some very interesting organizations
whose prefixes those were many of whom
we've talked to and worked with to try
to assess what was going on there if you
look at what sorts of things are going
on in these prefixes there's over half a
million domain names right that are
bound to eye peas that are in that space
that potentially where anybody to go to
any of those domains that traffic
hopefully it was all encrypted would be
intercepted by the in Turkey the guy who
interjects himself into the middle you'd
think that these would be maybe you know
hours long some of them are only minutes
long some of them are very fast we've
seen people hijack things like Bitcoin
servers or you take the address space of
some guy who's giving out bitcoins
solving problems and for a few minutes
you give out problems that you'd rather
have people solve that get credited to
you right so some of these things happen
for minutes we saw some that lasted for
months and on the internet if something
lasts for months that's kind of normal
right that becomes the new normal it's
it's unusual in that we see people
trying this and working the edges we see
them adjusting the the strategy that
they use to make sure that the poisoning
happens in exactly the right way kind of
disheartening we can see some of the
cities right you wouldn't expect this to
be a pinpoint operation people
everywhere we're impacted by this there
were hijacked networks all over
opportunistically right we can look at
what percentage of each country's
eyeballs if you will probably got fooled
by this remember hijacking means that
you only get fooled if you're close and
in some of these these were not these
were broadly propagated they were not in
fact you know carefully constrained and
so if the blue cities are where things
were being detoured from you can see
that some of these red places on earth
are places that were in very high
exposure but many many people there
because of the way their service
providers connect to people who are
close to the victim we're liable to get
there traffic read
during this time so it's truly a global
problem and it's probably just a few
guys you know sitting there in one
specific place just injecting these nets
so we made a big stink about this we
published a blog we took it to the press
the press finally set up and took a look
in 2013 in the springtime and said you
know you're right infrastructure is
important and maybe enough people had
not been paying attention to the
fragility of what was going on down at
routing level and so we actually got
some decent mainstream media attention
to the problem that the that you could
actually do these kinds of manipulations
and have these global effects and bgp
mischief slowed down let's i wish i
could say that you know we solved the
problem we we put out the fire but we
think we may have made it maybe it
slowed down a little bit maybe for three
to six months the men in the middle
stuff seemed to go way down we still saw
of the accidents because accidents
happen independently right they're not
intentional things but when we were
running trace routes through these
various hijackings we would not see
traces that go through the hijacking
place and then complete which is what we
wanted to see so but routing leaks are
always going to be with you as long as
you have network engineers who are
maintaining routing configs murphy's law
takes over people will publish things
that they don't own sometimes very large
piles of things and the filtering is so
poor those effects will will inevitably
have a real impact on somebody so the
reprieve that that that took place
lasted maybe six months and then it came
right back again and it's been getting
more and more sophisticated more and
more interesting in the last year we
just released a blog on the diner each
site its research dine calm in which we
detail some of the the fraudulent routes
that go on and this thing is an enormous
blog post where we poured about six
different specific incidents in there
that are happening right now that have
been happening recently
all kinds of different people doing it
all kinds of different victims scenarios
what drives this right how are we going
to fix this the problem is that the
problem of needing space on the internet
is pretty primordial we're running out
of ipv4 space it's almost all been given
out now it could be that these sorts of
things are what happens when the subway
car gets crowded and when the subway car
gets crowded people are going to start
throwing elbows right you're
accidentally going to be in somebody
else's space you're going to need space
you're not going to be able to get it
from the registries you're going to go
hunting for some vulnerable space you're
going to take it over for your purposes
if you want to send spam or host malware
if you just don't want to be attributed
for the thing you're doing this is why
we think this continues to happen we
could talk about defense I think there's
going to be a lot of great research
projects on how to defend against this
but I'm not confident that we're ready
to go there yet because we really need
to talk about attribution discovery okay
how do you figure out that this is
happening this is the question is there
centralized point of monitoring for this
no outside of a few specific
organizations that make this their job
like died research there's not a lot of
official word on the that would allow
you to arbitrarily go and figure out
that was happening if we really wanted
to shut this down we would need
everybody on the internet all 49,000
organizations everywhere on the planet
to use a route monitoring service right
and pay attention when the alarms go off
so that's not going to happen I would
love it if that happened it's not going
to happen yeah actually these 49,000 are
and knows about forty percent are sort
of stub a esas which is more than you
would hope but at least they're prepared
to speak bgp it's true you would think
that those would be that was where you'd
start you'd start by having their
providers filter them frankly I would
start by having everybody put their
routing policies what their think
they're trying to route what am I trying
to accomplish write it up and put it in
the IRR that alone
would allow people just construct
filters if people could get that right
if they can't get it right and human
nature says they're not going to get it
right then we're going to have to go use
some crypto so there are excellent
protocols that have been designed by
very smart folks to both secure the
origination every time I come up and I
am the origin for a network i'm going to
use public key crypto and sign that
thing so anybody on earth who receives
it can make sure that I'm allowed to do
that or that I said I was going two
turns out that that's not not sufficient
right because I can simply append a
legitimate origin to the end of my
illegitimate path and I'm the bad guy in
the middle of the path and nobody looks
in the middle of the path and we've seen
this start to happen so you have to use
something like bgp sec where you have
transitive encryption so every time i
receive an update first thing i have to
do is pull it open and make sure that
everything is valid all the way back to
the origin right and you know it's going
to look something like this I brought in
a little bit of an overview of what bgp
second description looks like you've got
to take the update you've received
you've got to open it up you want to
make sure that the guy who sent it to
you that it's properly protected and
then I'm going to have to wrap it in my
own layer before I pass it on to
somebody else that they in turn can go
validate that I was allowed to do that
all of it works it's it's deployed a
problem here is that that's a lot of
work and okay fine we have machines to
do the work right well our machines
right now are barely keeping up with the
scale of the internet right now you've
heard about the 512k problem where the
routing table got a little too big for
some legacy equipment that fell over so
imagine now when when bgp goes wrong
it's a very bursty protocol right I'm
something goes wrong on the other side
of the planet there's a cable cut well
now there's maybe tens of thousands of
routes from all those people on the
other side of that cable and they all
want right now bgp converge worldwide so
that they get their traffic nobody's
going to wait nobody's going to back off
they all want that to converge right now
that's a huge amount of bgp traffic that
comes at you whenever there's been one
of these big correlated failures that's
affecting large amounts of end-user
population so imagine now that instead
of just coping with the flood of BGP
updates as they arrived from that cable
cut I now have two laborious ly open
every one of them up and revalidate it
so there's two things that routers don't
have enough of ever memory and CPU
cycles and unfortunately crypto takes
both of those you know everything gets
bigger because you've got to keep track
of all the overhead and you've got to
deal with the processing requirements in
real time of validating all that stuff
years now that's the normally watch it
everybody wants it nobody seems to want
to do it right there are people who are
trying to deploy all of these solutions
and you're kind of you know it's like
preaching to the choir they know they
got to do it they'll do it the problem
is you have to get a critical mass of
people on earth to adopt these things
without the critical mass you know
there's no there's no chain of
authentication if we if we break the
chain and we've only got a partial
insight into how this is going to work
the protocols are great well knows goes
up by the door well this was this was
what the ipv6 folks I think worried
about even back in the day you know that
the routing tables a lot of ipv6 was
originally designed I think with the
current biggest fear in mind which you
know ten years ago was we're going to
run out of routing table space
completely legitimate as it turns out
concern I think that you know ipv6 has
had to fall back on a lot of the same
things that result in the routing table
being so large for ipv4 everybody wants
to multi-home everybody wants to be able
to do traffic engineering with small
blocks so as the Internet of Things
takes off there's only two solutions
there we either get really big routing
tables with everything being end
addressable or we fall back on something
like NAT so all of those internet of
things but those things aren't really
first-class citizens on the internet
they don't really have a portable IP
address they're all being translated
behind gateways so we can conserve the
IPS that we have
clean slate architecture question
starting all over today what you do wow
that's the question I never ever answer
right because by the time I were to cook
it up and get it out there it would be
wrong right and the problem is that that
you can design protocols that will make
the internet work but you can't get them
in the hands of all the people that need
to have them so I prefer to look at the
situation almost as an economist might
or a social scientist and say we've got
huge amounts of data that we can gather
from the system we can study it and find
the anomalies we can define what
merchant properties there are we can try
to come up with heuristics we can try to
come up with tipping points and nudges
and best practices you know we can reach
out with social networks of network
operators and try to have an impact on
the places that you need to have an
impact in order to get most of the
benefit but I've kind of given up on the
idea that we're ever going to forklift
upgrade the internet know to make it
right everything's gonna be good over
sort of any global warming situation
where the tipping point is fast and
we're double fault the drivers are human
psychology and economics right we the
minute that we saw that people wanted to
have their own address space right they
weren't Sofia le in ipv6 for example
that to keep the lid on this situation
people need to be happy with blocks of
addresses that are nicely hierarchical
and given out from their provider and
the fact that people said well no wait a
minute actually I get a lot of option
ality out of the fact that i have my own
address space I've provider independent
space that I can route I can fire my
provider i can get six more that
flexibility is something that
organizations prize and they won't give
that up without a fight it will say well
why do i have to be the guy who has to
do whatever my provider says and I have
to live inside his constraints I think
you know if we can hope that people
finally get to a point where we can have
trust on the internet
so until that day comes what are we
going to do here's what we're going to
do right we're going to take a look at
using historical data to figure out what
anomalies there are and chase them down
we don't have enough people to do this
even if you bring in all the emerging
markets people who need jobs let's like
do this algorithmically right let's
let's automate the finding of these
anomalies the problem is that there's a
lot of false positives and I'm going to
have to hurry because we want to wrap up
by five thirty but here's a false
positive right if I want to do this
right want to do it algorithmically okay
somebody the George Bush Foundation
George W Bush foundation announces a
brand new network and there accidentally
perhaps taking over a portion of a tease
bigger network so that goes off as an
alarm bell to us because we don't know
who that George W Bush Foundation is but
suddenly their routing a piece of a
TNT's address space now that's
legitimate because he was the first u.s.
president has his own a s by the way so
I applaud that but that's his provider
he borrowed some of their space with
their permission to run this foundation
routing accomplished right okay but is
that an alarm no that's a legitimate
thing but an alarming system inevitably
will flag that as an anomaly and it
causes noise in the system the
co-operative them and have them tell
Google that's right and hopefully there
would be something you know in their in
their registries that would point to the
fact that he had was a legitimate
customer but if they turn that route up
one day before you see it in the
registries for example it's still going
to set off an alarm bell that somebody
will have to track down so we've worked
out a whole set of these heuristics so
to allow us to suppress the false
positives did you do this in the past
people do engineering things all the
time briefly in an emergency and then
they put it away well if we've seen it
before it's less likely to be a true
anomaly today we want to see the true
things that have never ever happened we
want to suppress things that are only
seen by a few peers we want to suppress
things that are known anycast
infrastructure we talked about any cast
before right there's root servers and
and DNS servers and things that are
supposed to be everywhere they're
supposed to be spread around the world
so if you see 150
first persons start originating that
prefix you just ignore it well it's just
another instance of a fruit we have to
track the organization's behind all the
autonomous systems so level 3 probably
has I don't know dozens maybe hundreds
of a s numbers that they can lay some
claim to because they've grown through
mergers and acquisitions so if I see
Williams telecom just to use a fake
example originate a prefix the belongs
to level 3 that's less likely to be
anomalous because they have an economic
relationship good luck putting that in
an automated filter but that's what you
need to do there are services like
Prolexic that get in the way of of
traffic in order to scrub and filter
that's a legitimate commercial function
it's not a hijack and of course we do
the edit distance things digit reversals
and so forth to filter out the things
that are clearly just accidents network
for the technical new system to get the
business relationships in Oregon but so
we built up a database over time of what
we call cluster edges in the big a s
graph and routing helps because you will
typically see somebody's partner
organizations downstream of them in the
routing or at least doing some peering
and we have a special relationship tag
on those that says these two guys are
exchanging traffic it looks like peering
it looks like transit but really its
route to self same guy it's subject in
some sense I we sleep routine anonymous
rose to the rather than needing human
attention and will actually go and look
on Twitter will go and look you know in
the news find out is there enough some
merger acquisition activity going on and
you ahaha there are things that you can
potentially trade on in this data if I
tell you what they are then they will
cease to have value so I can't tell you
what they'll know as a specific example
we looked at we were watching the
routing of prefixes across the Caucasus
during the Georgian Russian war because
we knew that a lot of the fiber their
travels along the oil pipeline
and that pipeline was the target of
cruise missile attacks by the Russians
and we knew that if we saw a large
number of trans caucasus routes be
withdrawn from the BGP routing table it
was going to be a sign that the pipeline
was disrupted know someday it might be
possible for somebody smart to go in and
trade on information like that but it
tends to be very sporadic enormously
powerful yeah the real positives yes it
may but it's sort of a sort of a
bayesian thing right if there are a
hundred and fifty instances of having
spread that because it has a role to
play being spread than seeing one more
instance of it should have a lower
suspicion value than if there has always
been only one copy of this network and
today for the first time ever there are
200 it's an unofficial copy of a root
server maybe yeah in terms of ladies
what about time did you see another we
do we looked at what time these things
started and stopped because one of the
ways you can try to figure out where the
people sitting in the chair are is what
time of day they start and stop and they
do correlate to European sorts of
working day times for the ones that we
were describing so I guess you know you
say you know let's make sure we're not
throwing away the good stuff so trust me
that even after applying all of these
filters you end up with large piles of
potentially anomalous stuff and you want
to then rank them according to which
ones are the most unusual right so that
you give them your attention so we use
things like Geographic distance which
shouldn't make sense on the internet but
still we're humans this is a human
Internet so we look is the hijacking is
on the other side of the planet I mean
if it were two countries right next to
each other potentially that's a new
business relationship maybe that's you
know okay Kyrgyzstan is offering some
transit to Tajikistan because they can
just because it's novel doesn't mean it
wrong but you know if it the origination
is in Kyrgyzstan and the original
network is in Miami you know you're
worried more about it we look at what's
hosted in those domains so now that
we're now that we're DNS savvy having
emerged in with dine to take a look at
what the networks are being used for
what's hosted there is it bitcoin mail
servers why would somebody want that
space and if there's something good
there it's more suspicious we do the
trace based stuff again passing through
does it terminate is an impersonation or
is it man in the middle and in on and on
and we generate these things we get an
internal stream of these automated
reports and most of them even after all
that filtering are still not attacks
they're still not problems but you know
we get automated attacks like this one
so this was from the bell telecom
sequence where we're finding out the
prefix we automatically get the
autonomous system ownership we get the
geography for it we know how many of our
bgp peers how many of our reporting
sensors around the world got a sniff of
that wrong routing or anomalous routing
we know how long it stayed in the
routing table it's different right it
can be different if people are playing
games with visibility we know in this
case it was an average of you know a
little over an hour we know which prefix
it has punched a hole in we know what
autonomous system that is we know where
that thing normally lives and based on
that automated result somebody will have
to go and take a look so the problem you
know if I'm if I'm if I'm proposing
research directions for people and I
guess that's probably one of the things
that we should think about here this is
a global measurement problem if you just
go partner with one service provider and
convince them to give you a BGP feed you
will not see enough to get a sense of
the elephant that's in this room you
this any single enterprise any single
business that's trying to defend its
back-end defend its services is not
going to be able to defend itself from
its own perimeter it's going to take
global partnerships to get out there and
look over the horizon and see what you
look like from everywhere else on earth
that
not you because you're going to be the
last person to see these things when
they happen okay so we have to have the
the global network in order not to miss
anything we don't want false negatives
and we're going to want multiple
independent data sources bgp and ICMP
trace route bgp and dns records in order
to figure out which things are truly
anomalous right so that we minimize
false positives yeah and to look at
yourself you could so what that would be
like I suppose would be so if I talk to
a bank right a bank that wanted to know
what its own routes looked like around
the world could go out to for example
looking glasses that are operated by
service providers often for free kind of
a throwback to the old days and they
could go in manually and look themselves
up and see what routes were available to
them from providers around the world it
would be a manual process and it would
have to be done you know with a
frequency well what frequency do you
choose we know that these attacks can go
on for months so you know if you if you
get caught and you've been in an attack
that lasted for months that's pretty
embarrassing but a lot of these attacks
last four minutes or seconds a lot of
the linking losses don't support an
automated scraping although that doesn't
stop people from scraping them the
correct way to do it I suppose would be
to go out and do what we do which is to
talk to the service providers around the
world and say can you please add us the
diné research organization as one
additional adjacency so that we can keep
an eye on what the whole internet looks
like from your perspective and I'll show
you at the end some of the other data
sets that you could go to for this that
are not us but it's hard you have to
find a large number of people and they
have to have broad perspectives there's
a lot of providers that will say
absolutely and then they'll give you
just their customer routes and you'll
say well customer routes doesn't really
help me here because I'm not your
customer actually that's the basic
argument is why would that service
provider give me the time of day right
if he answers the phone from me he's
lost money
so a bank would have to go out and
probably bribe people to to give them
this data and it's the sort of thing
that aggregates up very nicely there can
be a few a few people on earth like dine
research that will will do it for
everybody in some sense and there are
there are academic research projects
that are doing that for everybody in
some sense and you know this is the bank
here's the bank the bank and from
dealing with with enterprises typically
running the internet is not their job
surprisingly enough they regard that as
a cost Center and they don't often
understand exactly what they're trying
to accomplish in terms of routing anyway
so they don't have the ground truth to
give you to create the ground truth for
monitoring so we actually end up having
to back into that by watching what
they've been trying to do for years and
sort of rolling it up and presenting it
and saying it looks like this is what
you're trying to accomplish is this
basically right and most organizations
can look at that and say wow we still
have an operation in Cleveland I thought
we shut that network down but eventually
it will converge and then you you take
that as the as the alarm configuration
you say good all right from this moment
forward you will receive bgp alarms when
this truth changes and for a lot of
organizations that's going to be
sufficient because they don't change
routing a lot of the time these guys who
are at the edge of the internet so they
should yes they do they pay money to
their service providers and ten years
ago 15 years ago service providers gave
you a lot more bang for your buck you
know you could get a lot more sort of
highly managed services in exchange for
buying transit from somebody but you
know those were the days where if I
bought a large circuit I might pay
hundreds of dollars per megabit
thousands of dollars per megabit you
know depending on the technology in the
geography these days in a major market
Western Europe North America you're
lucky to pay i'm going to say you know
tens of cents per megabit and at those
rates there's just not a lot of extra
money left over for people to do a lot
of sophisticated monitoring now a lot of
service providers have turned around and
said
fine we will offer additional managed
services on top of that and that's
probably a good differentiator if an
organization cares about that ask your
service providers and find out which of
them have this sort of willingness to to
to do a visibility service to do some
alarming on your behalf because they are
in a better position as the aggregator
to make it work charging many many
marriages that's more than what I'm
talking about for example there's an
optical link online Tokyo pushing it to
buy capacity open spaces but right do
those people offer okay and typically
these days when people get to charge
more on particular routes it's because
that route has something in its favor
it's typically not you know better
service it's typically reduced latency
first and foremost or the ability to
reserve a lot of bandwidth if you need a
lot of bandwidth so if I operate the
trans-siberian routes the terrestrial
routes that go across Russia that allow
you to avoid the submarine cables that
go from Europe to China they charge a
healthy premium over submarine cable
connectivity for those routes I don't
think the customer service is going to
be any better it's just that they can
charge more because there isn't as much
of it you know lynch 10 for example of
them from London to Tokyo is used only
for financial transactions that's right
and so I mean it absolutely is always
going to be somebody who will pay that
premium for you know shaving off
milliseconds or putting it in microwaves
to save the the the propagation delay of
light and fiber even on some routes
people are going up Arctic fibers going
across the North Pole to shave offs
milliseconds between Tokyo and London
which is amazing but the thought of
managed services and security and
vigilance and stuff is is is not a part
of the picture as often as it could be
as an additional thing you pay for yes
the best people who rolls to observe
this they're the most observation points
is the five eyes was there anything in
the Stoughton
about this not that I know of so have
you guys found it more fun to know more
this information uh yeah actually
there's a we sell well there shall be no
commercial content in a symposium
presentation yeah all right very good so
internet IP transit intelligence is a
product we do right now we're all of the
in the commercial relationships among
all of the service providers on earth in
each region are laid bare and the market
for that tends to be enterprises but
also the service providers themselves
we're trying to figure out how to make
money in this in this environment of
tightening margins I understanding
competition better and that's what we do
for them but route hijacking you know
our new product dine internet
intelligence does have a route hijacking
component because people keep asking for
it because this can this really can
happen to you it probably will never go
away worldwide I think unless you know
we all commit to watching carefully it
would be great to have more research
eyes on this if students are looking for
projects there are data sets you can go
for free and get your feet wet on this
modeling challenge Qaeda of course has
lots of data measurement lab has very
good stuff all of which is open Oregon
route views has a historical repository
of bgp updates and routing tables that
goes back a long way free for the taking
raipur is over in Europe equivalently
good data set these all have their
problems I will let you go find them out
you know as you crawl through the data
sets and you you find their limitations
but you know you can't beat the price so
and finally if anybody out there is
watching and wants to figure out how to
break into internet measurement the one
thing I would ask is that you take your
great ideas and go to these conferences
so go to nanog which is the North
American network operators group it's
right here in San Francisco and June go
to ripe in Amsterdam in May you know if
you need a reason to go to Amsterdam in
May you shouldn't need a reason to go
it's just incredible go to these
conferences meet the people who do this
for a living here there were stories by
them refreshments it pays back because
every great idea that you probably have
an Internet measurement or how to
improve the internet they've heard them
all and it would be great to have some
some framing context I think for some of
the research that goes on because these
guys you know these are the guys who
carry the pagers in the middle of the
night to keep the internet flowing and
with that I think we've run right out of
time so thanks
you